[Musique]
k now
la ville n'existait pas il ya dix ans
elle accueille aujourd'hui plus de
300000 habitants tous des sinistrés du
séisme
quand je suis arrivé ici il était la
troisième personne toute la terre était
complètement vide s'est ralentie de
désert lui gilbert pierre louis est venu
s'installer ici avec sa femme il y a
huit ans qui n'en était alors un immense
terrain vague sans service il fallait
aller chercher l'eau à port au prince
c'était vraiment eu les airs il ya le
soleil qui est très chaud il ya un grand
vent qui soufflait d'état où il ya de la
poussière mais quand même j'ai dit je
dois tenter ma chance pour voir que
c'est à voir
gilbert et sa femme ont vécu sous les
tentes après le tremblement terre pour
tenter de vider ces camps de fortune le
gouvernement a alloué aux sinistrés des
lopins de terre l'occupant ne paie pas
de loyer et après 10 ans devient
propriétaire au début la vie était très
dur à cannes a surtout avec des bébés
mais lévy n'a jamais songé à repartir
je me sens vraiment bien il ya des
moments qui vraiment d'eau pour moi 2
par exemple il ya parfois il fait très
beau il y avait des oiseaux qui sont ici
je ne me tente pas des bruits les gros
sont parce que je ne peux pas supporter
la bosse on continue avec les classes de
la femme se confinait isolé mais si on
en attend les loups du bal à tort et à
travers
on a été sérieux rien d'actuel si je
meurs demain c'est naturel c'est celle à
plus de ben e
le comédien et chanteur mathias est
devenu un des leaders de la contestation
populaire
lui et son groupe jeunesse mais propre
réclame non seulement le départ du
président joël moïse mais la réforme
totale d'un état corrompu un état
mafieux selon l'artiste qui a détourné
la grande partie des milliards donnés
pour la reconstruction du pays
il se souvient du 12 janvier 2010
comme si c'était hier c'était cet effet
m c'était noir s'étaient semble y avait
des gens qui qui couraient partout sans
savoir ni c'est comme des oiseaux qui
dit moins dans leur propre camp je vois
l amour plus tard dans l'après midi je
vois l espoir pour une fois il ne
fallait pas reconnaître ton nombre de
dieu et à dormir avec moi et bien manger
avec moi c'était l'unification parfaite
malheureusement notre politicaillerie
comme d'habitude a repris le dessus
cette politique a écrit produit le
désespoir dit il mais les haïtiens
restent fiers de leur pays
fiers de leur histoire d'avoir été les
premiers à se libérer de l'esclavagé on
est ficelé pour vivre libres les accès
sont sont conçus pour la liberté on est
on est conçu pour cette liberté ne l'est
pas il faudrait pas qu'elles sont vos
chaînes aujourd'hui l'ambassade
américaine certainement d'astra
canadienne certainement la balade de
france on est en pleine dictature celle
d'une dictature officialisé officialisée
par les par les nations étrangères qui
supportent et ce jour dell moïse comme
l'on dit qui a pour moi un ordre duo
politique de visas
nous verrons le 13 janvier peu importe
qu'on soit 13 à 13 milles
nous serons devant l'ambassade
américaine lance-t-il en invitant la
population à reprendre les
manifestations lundi prochain
la couturière married warren important
d'aller manifester mais c'est chouette
les mêmes changements radicaux que les
jeunes c'est pas avoir cité assure
qu'elle a vu là qui fait tout le monde
quel que soit leur offrir pour quitter
haïti autour du thé haïti parce que
paris vient mais si nous gagnons nous et
travail
et puis elle doit nous respecter ses
doigts nouveau n'est respecté a dit tout
et nous maquiller sécurité tout le monde
ne doit pas l'être il faire agréer sur
vous songez à auvelais marie via canal
depuis bientôt dix ans elle deviendra
propriétaire de cette petite maison dans
quelques mois
le jouet d'un côté on doit me nous
papier parce que nous les vtt ont la vie
dure à kano les gens n'ont pas d'argent
pour me payer 10 la couturière qui fait
des uniformes pour les écoliers mais au
moins ici on peut devenir propriétaire
merci je dis que c'est une conséquence
positive ou six parce qu'il beaucoup de
jeunes avec à la maison maintenant ils
ont la clé une maison et un quartier
tranquille pour élever leurs deux jeunes
filles qui vont à l'école
gilbert a maintenant les moyens de payer
une école privée car il a un emploi à
cahors les sonnailles si vous travaillez
pour moi c'est une glace est une
bénédiction parce qu'il faut qu'il y ait
des gens qui laissent pour contribuer au
développement du pays
la lumière de faire lui mais je suis de
la cité soleil gigantesque bidonville
qu'on connaît tous je suis un petit
garçon on compte qu'on était obligé de
rêver parce que en haïti a certains qui
n'ont pas le droit de rêver
aujourd'hui six jeunes se donnent le
droit de rêver de révolution on a ce
discours ferme de refaire l'état de
reconstruire l'état au rêve d'une
nouvelle indépendance avec de nouveaux
héros